con gritos de Dios es grande la yihat
islámica en tierra a sus víctimas
murieron tras los ataques israelíes en
gaza unas horas antes la ciudad de
hallowness fue uno de los objetivos
algunos señalan que el ejército israelí
no habría advertido a los habitantes
como lo ha hecho otras veces
estaba en casa con mi esposa y mis hijos
durmiendo la primera explosión ocurrió y
todos nos despertamos mire por la
ventana y vi humo y escombros
este jueves a fuerza aérea de Israel
difundió imágenes en la que se muestran
sus nuevos ataques contra objetivos de
la yihadi islámica Palestina en la
franja de gaza varias de las víctimas
serían líderes del grupo pero también
murieron varios civiles entre ellos
niños en Israel las autoridades dicen
que más de 500 cohetes palestinos han
sido disparados contra su territorio en
los últimos días llaman a los residentes
a permanecer en los refugios y las
escuelas han sido cerradas en un radio
de 40 kilómetros alrededor de la franja
de gaza mientras que los cohetes de la
yihad son interceptados en gran medida
por la defensa antimisiles de Israel en
Severo y scalon algunos han hecho daño
desafortunadamente experimentamos Esto
hace dos días
realmente espero que se detenga Y que
nuestro gobierno despierte y les pegue
duro como se merecen
si bien ambas partes prometen continuar
con sus acciones las Naciones Unidas
están preocupadas por un incremento en
la escalada de las tensiones según
Fuentes diplomáticas Egipto intenta
mediar para obtener un alto al fuego